[Music]
joining me now is Democrat New York
assembly member Jamie Williams who's
also a parent of a student at James
Madison High School assemblywoman thank
you for joining us I know you went to
the school last night um you're a parent
yourself and your reaction to what
happened and the response from the
officials thank you Laura for having me
um definitely um concerning as a parent
as a representative for the area very
disruptive to our students it's not fair
to our parents AR I was also there this
morning and the community is just
outrage because here you have the
migrants being placed over our own
children and our community what's
next well assemblywoman you found this
poster directing the migrants to local
government officials including yourself
if they need anything again kids are
falling behind in test scores Etc uh
your reaction to that priorities I don't
think it was uh a poster for them to you
know if they needed something clearly um
myself and a council member Ena vov um
it was to let them know if we are back
on the scene to not let us into the
building oh so they were trying to
prevent you as a taxpayer and as an
assembly woman elected by your
constituents as a parent from Gaining
access to the facility you you all pay
for the facility we pay for the facility
guess what it's taxpayers money and
there needs to be
accountability and we have taken a
national issue which the federal
government the Biden Administration has
turned a blind eye to to put it into the
most residential community in the
southeast side of Brooklyn and now our
residents have to deal with such an
issue and that's unfair to us it's aair
unfair to each taxpaying
American but don't you agree that if Joe
Biden wanted this to end
tomorrow he has the tools to do that I
mean this border was fairly secure just
a few years ago assembly woman but rich
people in the United States want this
border to stay open they like the cheap
labor and all the other benefits that
they get so why wait till tomorrow I
would just districts are benefactors of
lawlessness we can't wait until tomorrow
we have to turn off the main at the
faucet and that is closing our
borders plain and simple there's no
tools to find there's no new words to
invent it's plain English close the
borders and let's deal with the
situation instead of putting the
American
citizens in a predicament where you have
other people over them it's unfair to
each and every taxpaying American not
only in my district but in this
country it is not fair to us
assemblywoman I appreciate your
perspective come back with us soon we're
going to keep reporting on this because
I don't think this is ending I think
this is going to continue hey Sean
Hannity here hey click here to subscribe
to Fox News YouTube page and catch our
hottest interviews and most compelling
analysis you will not get it any
anywhere
else